Biden is attacking the legitimacy of the
court because he doesn't like the
particular verdicts that's that's all
there is to it so I want to talk about
the legitimacy of the Court the Supreme
Court has an institution
um interestingly uh while uh responding
to questions about the uh affirmative
action ruling uh President Biden was
asked uh has uh you know that the
Congressional Black Court caucus said
the Supreme Court uh by virtue of its
affirmative action
uh Rowling has thrown into question its
own legitimacy President Biden was asked
is this a rogue Court
and uh the president answered this is
not a normal court and I just want to
point out uh also at the same time the
Supreme Court job approval uh this is
from uh last year at Gallup
um it's the most recent that I could
find but it has seen a fairly
precipitous drop over the past couple of
years uh down to 40 percent of people
saying that they approve it if you go to
other Gallup records just to give a
sense of this
um uh 25 of people say they have a great
deal or quite a lot of confidence in the
Supreme Court and that's down from 45 in
1973. uh Wally if I can go to you first
uh you know is this a normal court is
this a legitimate Court are these
questions we should be seriously
considering what the court did in
particular in these two cases uh was
telegraphed I would argue 20 or 25 years
ago in earlier cases and in fact of all
the things the court has done let's hear
the results in these two cases were
among the most predictable and would
have happened uh had there been some
president other than Trump for example
on the uh they were not considered close
cases by the majority and so forth now
is the court legitimate uh you know
interesting question in which you have
seen uh I would argue a number of forces
attacking the Court's legitimacy
including both a bunch of people on the
left who combined being sore at outcomes
of cases we can all go through the ones
there but with also being sore
procedurally at the various confirmation
battles which you know I agree that you
know Congress has disgraced itself or
the Senate has disgraced itself at
various times in its conduct but there
there are sore about particular
vacancies that they believe should have
gone to democratic a point is and then
on the uh the Maga side we all know what
Trump thinks of the legitimacy of Courts
which is he calls them so-called judges
if they will against him
um so so you have as part of the general
um polarization you have this and other
institutions
um uh that are the subject of more
demonization and delegitimization
campaigns you could we could go on all
day about the pluses and minuses if that
there are Libertarians who'd say good no
confidence in government institutions I
am the other kind of classical liberola
who thinks no we're courting dangers if
we undercut institutions that we may all
need to rely on yeah and uh just to put
the court decline from 45 people having
a uh a great deal or quite a lot of
confidence and Trust in in the
institution of the Supreme Court down 45
percent or down to 25 from 45 1973
Congress uh in 1973 had a confidence
rating of 42 percent that's down to
seven percent and the presidency is down
from 52 and 75 which was the first year
that Gallup passed it down to 23 so in a
way the court is mirroring the same kind
of decline we see in the other branches
of government Coleman what about you
what do you think I mean should we be
worried about these kind of broad-based
attacks on the legitimacy of the court
is this something to be worried about
well yeah I mean I think uh the truth is
Biden is attacking the legitimacy of the
court because he doesn't like the
particular verdicts that's that's all
there is to it
there's nothing in the Jewish
jurisprudence of these decisions that
calls into question the the soundness of
Mind of Supreme Court Justices
and
Biden and you know Democrats and
liberals in general have had no
qualms with the legitimacy of the court
on the Voting Rights uh cases that have
come out in the past month
um two of which have gone towards what
would be characterized usually as sort
of the liberal position one in Alabama
and one with a federal oversight uh of
of State legislatures in general
um so obviously this is just you know
this is a political attack this this
should not actually be taken seriously I
think the court is legitimate
and uh and it's important from a
separation of powers perspective that it
continue to be seen as such the Supreme
Court's you know a positive approval
ratings have dipped uh you know as I was
saying uh 25
of people according to Gallup have a
great deal or quite a lot of confidence
in it it's down from 45
uh in 1973 which is what 50 years ago
um you know uh and it's it's in lockstep
with other declines but is there
anything that the Supreme Court can do
going forward to kind of restore
it sense uh you know restore confidence
and in that it is working through these
things in the way that it's supposed to
as opposed to in kind of cheap political
ways
big question and part of it is how well
they explain themselves part of it is
when justices dissent whether they do so
in language that undercuts the
legitimacy of the majority uh or vice
versa and part of it is a process that
you certainly can see if you look up
close to the cases that the court takes
and how they decide them which is that
although they are not swayed by public
opinion to do things they wouldn't do
affirmatively they will sometimes duck
kisses and rule narrowly for fear of
being demonized Again by some of the
same groups that are just waiting to
demonize them I find that unhealthy I
will say looking back over the last few
years the courts have been one of the
few institutions the federal courts in
particular that actually have done what
they needed to during a potential
constitutional crisis you know they were
the ones who turned down all the
frivolous election suits and I worry
that
um uh sniping out them for short-term
gain over various issues that uh they
decide means that the public support
will not be there when they need to make
a perhaps unpopular decision
upholding uh the right side in an
election dispute that was an excerpt
from our reason live stream with Walter
Olson of the Cato Institute and Coleman
Hughes talking about recent Court
decisions dealing with affirmative
action and whether or not website
operators had to serve gay couples if
you want to see another excerpt go here
if you want to see the full thing and
you should go here